the Joe Rogan experience it's nice to do
this [ __ ] about being at a rap concert
Busta Rhymes and zall white folks and
I'm there and he goes all my real [ __ ]
make some noise everybody made noise
like the two of the black malarious but
can you cheer right so then I go well
maybe maybe they didn't hear him but in
hip-hop you say everything twice again
like I said all my real [ __ ] Rachel
boy and so I was like man not only
people [ __ ] now who's now saying I was
doing this [ __ ] like in Milwaukee I'll
go and not only can we call them [ __ ]
they paying $80 for the privilege to be
called $80 a ticket then I'll go white
folks tonight I'll call you [ __ ] for
ten ten dollars [ __ ] sale [ __ ]
clearance cash only because I know how
you [ __ ] are right so proud of this
bit at the end of the show I'm selling
my dumb DVDs you know some emerge and
inevitably a white person would always
come up to me give me $20 and call me
Nick so late twenties early thirties you
you you know you know you know you're
the angry comment like what the [ __ ] you
know and then now that I'm alone I go
man I'd be funny if I cuz I kept the
money you know like if that was my stick
like I didn't sell more call me whatever
you want
I made my money by people walking back
[Laughter]
[Applause]